my pro football hall of fame friend we
have found him he is here on the rich
eyes and show he's rod watson how you
doing rod
rich i am doing fine let me let listen i
heard your the little thing about rudy
yes and i know really losing vegas i
live in vegas so if you want me to help
you out here and yes rudy's pissed at me
because i keep saying that the movie's
fake and he's and and it's uh it's if
you want me to walk up to the door and
ring the doorbell for you i gotta do it
do it rod you know what rod it's it's
all coming up maze and blue these days
isn't it so yeah
right
now it's the true story that beau
recruited you but he was way too intense
for you and that's isn't that a true
story rod right
no no not bo no no i met bo
for the first time at the playboy
all-american yes um when they had that
back in the day after my sophomore year
at purdue
i met bo talked to him but he didn't
recruit me for anything over there not
if not for not going down near to auburn
did notre dame ever recruit you ron did
you did you they did
they wanted me to take two ap courses my
senior year written i'm like uh that's
okay
[Laughter]
see the provost they need they needed
you to get your they needed to get
things up for you to be admitted to
notre dame is that what you're saying
right they need your grades that's what
they wanted but i'm like you know what
i'd rather i'd rather go to purdue
they're not asking me to take two ap
courses this is great here's a great
story too i've heard this one you told
me this one indiana how did india why
didn't you go to indiana why didn't
mystery indiana go to miss to indiana
this is great this is great go for it so
you know coach um gosh
now i'm losing him
he was driving up to see me he knocks on
my door
and he
tells me who he is which i already knew
he was and then he told me that he heard
that he was fired while he was driving
to see me
and he i'm telling you what to do was
real he's a great ambassador for
indiana university i mean university of
indiana the hoosiers because he gave him
a lot of love and he still wanted me to
go there and i was like coach they fired
you over the radio that's amazing like
if they fired you over the radio and you
did all that for them what would they do
to me if i got hurt what do you say
he really didn't have an answer
[Music]
and last one though
trumps it all arizona state tell me that
one you got to tell me the arizona state
story come on now i mean arizona state
you know go there they don't have a
coach and i can't remember the name of
my host but he was a tight end and you
know i'm a 17 year old knucklehead kid
from indiana i don't know who gandhi is
i mean i know gandhi but i really don't
know what it is right so he was like you
want to go see gandhi and i'm like
sure
the movie you know the movie the movie
the movie it's a three and a half hour
movie with the intermission
so we go at like 5 30 or whatever it is
by the time it's over it's 9 30 10
and he's like what do you want to do now
i'm like man you can take me back to my
room and tell your guys i'm going to
purdue
so one of the greatest defensive backs
in the history of football i can call
you that you don't have to you we all
know you are could have gone to arizona
state had the tight end who was in
charge of your recruiting visit not said
let's go see a three and a half hour
movie or any movie at all right pretty
much you know because
it was i'm glad he did because if i
would want the arizona state rich i
don't know if you ever heard about me
i think i would have flunked out you've
been hooting with the owls yeah what are
you saying that's a that's a party
university right so
that was that was probably with the the
best day night the best decision i've
made when i was a kid is not to go to
arizona state rod woodson's recruiting
story right here on the rich eisen show
okay rod let's jump into it um do you
think
what what do you make of the steelers
what is going on what what what do you
see when you watch this team right now
rod
well when their defense plays really
well they win
and you know people can always say they
always want to give it back and go back
to the the run game and that is a part
of it
uh and and i love what mike tomlin said
this past week when
uh when claypool wanted music
you know he was like you know the music
we're going to be having is pop or pads
popping
that's our music and they really got
back to that they got back to the
steeler way of doing everything the
defense played extremely well i mean tj
watt if he doesn't win demons a player
of the year this year
you know shame on all the voters
um he's played outstanding football and
then when they have a run game and bend
on top when he doesn't turn the ball
over they play decent football and
you know it'd be a great indication this
week when they play cleveland excuse me
when they got minnesota the viking
tomorrow night
to see if
to see if they can beat a team that not
used to seeing
and that's what i want to see if they
can be consistent yeah they they put a
couple games together uh earlier in the
year
but i just need to see if they can be
consistent if they can be consistent you
know i don't know if they're the best
team in the you know obviously
baltimore's the best team
uh
in the north but
you know they have an opportunity
because i don't think there's a
one great team in the afc this year yeah
marlon humphrey being knocked out i mean
how many teams
like the ravens keep on taking the licks
and keep on ticking to use the old watch
phrase you know but
um that one marlon humphrey that one i
th genuinely concerns me do you think
that would even
you know they they say screw it we're
playing defensively that we like to play
it uh no matter sometimes down distance
score what have you but do you think
that one might actually cause the the
ravens to
a couple things what do you think i i
think it will um you know you got to
understand also what you know
what happened at the beginning of the
year before the season even started
uh
losing a marcus um and the other
starting corner on the other side marcus
peterson
and now you lose humphreys and i know
wink
wink likes to show that look and bring
pressure
and i mean obviously it impacted
john harbaugh's decision to go for two
yes
right so
you know is it going to be impactful for
the rest of this year i think a will
if the coaches let it you know obviously
you know you you do have a 53-man roster
he is your best cornerback that plays
for the baltimore ravens but you got to
hope that your young guys can play
really good football enough for you and
then you got to hope that the offense
kind of comes back around because they
haven't played great
and you know outside of this past week
they were winning football games few
minutes left here with rod woodson pro
football hall of famer right here on the
rich eisen show i mean you remember 2001
just coming off of the the win for the
ravens and then the patriots started
that kid brady and then all of a sudden
they
caught fire towards the end of the
season and nobody thought they could
make the playoffs they did nobody
thought they could actually go deep in
the playoffs they did nobody thought
they could win the super bowl they did
even though nobody thought that they
would
you know try and win it in regulation
and they did and then suddenly the
confetti is coming down do you think
we're seeing the same thing again here
with mac jones and the pats
rod uh you know what
they they have played extremely well
and
i i love the way
bill belichick
and
mcdaniel's had only three passes in the
game this past week
now
you know i i think that shows those two
things they they understood the the
climate they're playing in and i don't
know if they really trust
you know a young quarterback like jones
to throw the ball in a win like that i
mean it was extremely windy where josh
allen who has a strong arm it kind of
his his balls were cut through the wind
um but the the biggest issue i have with
that game and i'll get back to your
answer sure is like why did that take
two and a half quarters
for the buffalo bills to realize they're
not throwing the football
they're not throwing the football we can
blitz some of these runs
and they finally figure that out you
know probably midway through the third
quarter that we're going to really load
the box and bring our backers and our
safeties down
um you know but i like
matt jones i like
he do what i think was two weeks ago he
do uh what we call uh uh chair seven so
the number three receiver ran a
seven cut or like to the back pylon
he was a three by one and he threw it
before he broke
that's not normal rich
that's not normal to see a rookie
quarterback throw the ball that early
they normally wait to see you get open
then they throw it in the boss too late
then it sails out of bounds
he's been throwing the ball and making
throws like a veteran player
and that's what i like to see and that
gives me a lot of promise for the past
you know and i hear the
you know the comparison of tom brady
tom brady one he's he won quite a few
super bowls right right right right
that's right pretty pretty pretty good
but i think what he has and he's my i
think he's played better than tom brady
coming into it
his first year as a starter you know and
you know because remember when tom took
over their defense was
life out
for new england
and their defense is good this year but
the way
jones has played this year i think a
little bit better than what brady when
he started um
i like what they're doing i just don't
know
if they can
win i mean if they get home field
advantage it's going to be tough to play
in new england late in the year right in
january we know that but if they don't
um
i just don't know if they can beat the
best teams
you know for three rounds or two rounds
and get to the super bowl rod watson
here on the rich eisen show last one for
you brady
um one sports person of the year for
sports illustrated last night rod and
the reason why i bring it up is there
was a piece in an article that came out
with the announcement in which this
quote he said and it kind of jumped out
at me
and i'm wondering what you think about
this your guy's been playing many many
many played many years and wound up in
the room where brady's gonna wind up
with the same bust uh in the same bus
room as you this what he said quote i
think if anything the most challenging
part you mentioned about playing right
now is the emotional aspect of football
for me when we lose it's depressing
when we win it's a relief it's not like
the joy the happiness it's a relief
because when we win sometimes just
winning isn't good enough for you
what do you think when you hear that rod
well
you know
he's
most guys like him and you know i
retired
because i was tired of going through the
rigors of having surgery and coming back
from a surgery
he he it's his choice he has a certain
level of play that he wants to play
um
and he's rewarded by the wind
and to me it is emotionally draining to
play that long as long as he's played i
mean it's that's a long time
yeah i don't know how many more years he
has you know i think
if he plays if they win again they go
back to back i think he might i think he
drops the mic and walks off
and he he gets he gets a job with espn
nbc cbs with somebody right
and he's making a lot of money doing
commentating if he wants it he doesn't
need it
um but if he wants it so i i give him if
they win this year i think he drops the
mic and i think he's done to me that
language sounded like that was the
language of a coach that's just like the
losing lasts so much longer than the
wins do and and
i was kind of surprised to hear that
does that sound like a guy who's
thinking about it
to you i think i think it does because
it is draining it's i mean to be to get
emotionally jacked up weekend a week out
for 21 years rich
i mean that is that's hard and your kids
are young you want to be with your kids
you're trying to you know hang around
them but he's going to put a lot of time
in off season again
um i think that's that's indication
where you know i think you can hear
where it's kind of going because a young
tom brady wouldn't say that
right a guy that was 10 years into the
spain or eight years into it or five
years into it he never said that but the
older brady did and i think that's
indication of him
maturing in his life and he knows how
taxing it is
you know mentally week in a week out to
get ready for that and to go through
those rigors
on game day
um and i you know he has that standard
that he wants to play at
so i think if he really gets that win
um
you know he's dropping the mic and yeah
it is taxing even for coaches well
coaches you know it does linger a little
bit more
um when you do lose um and you relieve
when you do win
so but brady's been coaching for the
last
12 years 10 years anyway he's been the
coach right i mean he's been coaching
his guys on the field so he's been that
coach good point he just
he technically doesn't have the title
but he's been that guy i just found that
whole quote uh from brady interesting so
um last thing for you rod uh since
you're a purdue guy and a big ten guy
you root for michigan now right the rest
of the way correct i i will i mean they
got to represent anybody who's going to
get you know from big ten that gets into
the playoffs they got to represent the
big chance don't you think is it is it
it's a tough task though rich why
because because it's the sec because if
they're going against the sec right
it's one of it's one of the best
defenses
that i've seen in a long time in college
football now they they did get kind of
ran through against you know alabama
and you got to think is
you know think about jim harvey what he
is he's a he's a smash mouth physical
can they run the football
like they did in the in the championship
game
against georgia what do you think of it
what do you think of aiden hutchinson
does he look like a top choice in the
nfl draft
he is
he he is a he's a dog
that's what you know
uh
we always say in the locker room and i
think the
especially the older players who are
retired when you can say hey i would
like to play with a guy like that that
gives a lot of respect to
who he is
i i would like to play with a guy like
that wow he has that he has that motor
he has that energy he's athletic he
never stops every play matters to him it
doesn't matter if it's to his ball side
or away from him he's going to chase the
ball down i love players like that
rod the win over ohio state and then
after that has made me uh uh such a
happy guy it's unsettling how happy it's
made me
you know it's
i know it has rich
it's really it's unsettling it's really
you know ever since 2003 when i got to
get to know you i mean it just hasn't
been more more l's than dubs so this has
been great
it's been and i was happy to see jimmy
finally get that monkey off his back and
beat ohio state and i and i love his
little
his little one-liner when he got when
his interview after the game when he
said you know you you wake up on third
and you think you hit a triple
i was like yes
take care of yourself rod let's chat
soon all right take care right back at
you
right back guys rod watson
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here